maxine was at home with his girlfriend
when the shells started crashing into
his village
shrapnel ripped through his arm and face
it happened so quickly the explosions i
heard something flying over us i was
covered up to my waist in rubble and
something started burning i tried to
free myself then i tried to get my
girlfriend i was so weak i couldn't pull
her out
emergency services rescued maxim's
girlfriend
she's suffering heavy concussion and is
too weak to talk
the bodies of three civilians lie in the
morgue
a woman died in the operating theater as
doctors tried to save her life this
woman who was afraid to talk on camera
says russian soldiers let her family
escape but as they drove away a bullet
ripped through her husband's hand
why did they tell us everything would be
okay why wasn't there an evacuation she
says
we drive to the village there's the
sound of shelling and machine gun fire
in the distance
the shells had slammed into houses on
the side of this hill
piles of rubble lined the street at
least 30 homes were destroyed
heavy russian shelling of this village
last night at least three people were
killed
a number of others injured we understand
that there are people still in the
village but we've just heard shelling in
the distance and machine gun fire in the
forests on the way
thousands of cars many of them filled
with terrified families flee south from
kharkiv
many of the cars have a sign reading
children on the windscreen a desperate
attempt to protect those inside
we are leaving everything behind us we
have been trying for five days to get
out but couldn't because of the shelling
it's simply how we are going to nipro
and after that we don't know
alexey shows us his car that was damaged
when a russian rocket landed close to
his home
i've just spoken to friends in kharkiv
they tell me it's worse than yesterday
they are shelling civilian areas so many
buildings are on fire
people have painted over road signs with
angry insults directed towards russian
president vladimir putin
an expectation of a russian army advance
this one reads
welcome to hell
charles stratford al-jazeera yakulivka
ukraine